Oh my gosh, I need to...
I need to stop floating.
I need to...
Oh!
I need to start...
I need to start running instead of floating all the time.
Hello!
Nice get up.
Wow.
Wow!
Hi!
Wow, you found me!
The ghost of the beach!
You're all dressed up for...
Volleyball?
Rugby?
Who would have thought?
I thought today was my new outfit, but I think actually it's
your new outfit.
Water polo!
Wait, how do you guys... Wait, it's you!
Of course you all know.
Right, right, it makes sense.
It makes total absolute sense.
Of course, of course.
Yes, that makes so much sense.
Waterpole.
Is the cap?
Is it really?
I've gained some great abs.
Yeah, you look great.
I wish, though, you covered up a little bit more.
I'm a little scared.
A little frightened.
Hello everybody.
Hi.
Welcome to the beach.
Wow.
This is a beautiful day at the beach.
Oh my gosh.
It's so relaxing.
You're ready for water polo.
On the beach.
I thought it was volleyball.
Wait, you guys are telling me it's not?
But that's so...
Wait, what if it's like beach football?
What if we're having like a top gun moment?
Why are we Mega Man?
I don't know, you dress this way.
You tell me.
You tell me why you are the way that you are.
You don't wear a hat like that.
the beach okay then take it off i don't know it's your
outfit
how is horse magnifying i was watching you deconstruct and
reconstruct horses
thank you kombakua everyone hi we're we're enjoying this
lovely beach um uh evening evening evening Evening, evening,
evening.
Yes, while I am definitely paying attention to all my notes
and things of things I must take care of.
Yeah, yeah.
But...
I mean, you guys haven't said much about my outfit.
Is it beach suitable?
Is it beach ready?
Am I ready for the beach?
Beach bus light year.
Not really.
Not at all.
It's my normal outfit.
But like, what?
You call me to the beach.
That's cool.
You call me to the beach?
You call me to the beach and you say, Hey, get here as fast
as you can.
I have a surprise.
I didn't expect the surprise to be a speedo.
Or water polo at the beach.
So I didn't have time.
I didn't have time to get anything for the beach.
It is summer too, right?
I should update for summer it's my birthday suit you better
not be I didn't dress myself mean though are you is that a
wave are you saying your mom dressed you
yeah yeah I just woke up I was here you're finally awake she
said I look good it's like when toddlers dress themselves
and they have like two different socks and do you guys
remember when two different socks were trendy though
actually wait a second
wait wait but as also i feel like it's it's it's like a
vtuber trend as well no to have two different socks What if
you're not wearing socks?
What if I have no socks?
What do I do?
She's so trendy.
VTuber and gotcha.
Oh yeah, right?
Gotcha characters also don't have matching socks.
socks.
One high sock, one low sock.
To be fair, I've done this since 2020.
So, I'm a pioneer.
I'm a pioneer of this game, all right?
I've actually, but I think actually my first outfit had
matching socks.
Wait a second.
Don't worry about it.
The Trailblazer.
we um we're gonna chit chat before we before i you know
we'll let the sun go down it's so nice we'll enjoy this
lovely evening and and everything yeah we love chatting we
want we want we want everybody who wants to play on the
beach water polo we want everybody who wants to play water
polo to get here.
How do you play water polo?
I don't even know.
One slightly cold leg.
It's like sticking your leg under the covers, you know?
When you're too warm and you stick one leg out and you're
like, yeah, that's all I needed.
That's all I needed.
You play it in a pool.
Well, not today, I guess.
Today's the beach, baby.
Someone screams water and you gotta say polo.
Wait, I know that game.
Where you close your eyes and somebody goes...
No, that's Marco Polo.
Wait, wait.
If I say Marco, you guys say polo, okay?
I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna get you, get you, get you, get you.
water don't go too far out might be scary
one guide to the max don't the horses drown when you play
water polo yeah because polo is usually on horses no are we
the horse you called so are we oh my gosh have you guys seen
those that like I don't know it seems I want to say
hobbyists but it seems more lifestyle than hobby where the
girls are on I don't say I say girls just because horse
girls you know but the people they're on horse sticks you
know like it's like a broomstick but the broom part is a
horse head right hobby horsing yes yes yes yes and then you
you pretend you are the horse, but also riding the horse.
Competitive hobby horsing.
If you've never heard of it before, I recommend looking it
up.
It's a...
It's something.
It's too cringy.
I can't even think about it.
No!
no is it safe for work yes yes yes i people will like strut
around like they are a horse but they are also riding like
the legs are the horse are you know like my my leg my legs
are the horse legs but i am also riding the horse who is
that stinky man matara khan that's you Does this count as
the fan service beach episode?
Pia, super excited for the outfit, Minto.
Thank you, Lunar.
It might.
I think beach episode has got to be the fan service episode,
right?
Will there be fan service?
It's an umamusume at home.
Kind of, yeah.
Will there be fan service?
service I mean I'm a maid that all I provide is service
exactly two years since MGS con to deja vu I'm
sorry that haunts you maybe I should have made it so you
guys didn't have the little hat then it could have been
volleyball then we could have pretended top gun or something
you know we could have pretended little bit manifesting mint
hobby horsing next time i do a 3d stream just remind me i'll
show you my hobby horsing skills what if i just do a hobby
horsing stream i'm writing that down i'm writing it down the
mega man hat is growing on me is it are we mega man are we
buzz light year i'm getting identity crisis I need I need I
need to know who are you who are you one haircut away from
being beach mission guys mega man mega man mega man I am a
bug yeah you're bugging me I'm a tall I you know I'm also
I'm feeling a little self-conscious now.
I'm feeling a little self-conscious that you guys are... I'm
mama!
Mama!
Everybody say hello to Ayami Sensei.
Ayami Mama!
Everybody say hello.
Hi Ayami Mama.
Hi Ayami.
Ami-sensei.
Hello, hello.
But yeah, I'm feeling a little self-conscious.
You know, maybe I should...
Maybe I should go over...
I could find a boutique.
And then we'll play water polo or something.
I don't want to play water polo.
I was ready for...
Top gun.
Beach volleyball.
I feel like I've been...
Bamboozled.
Oh, it's the law.
It's fire down, bro.
No!
We can play volleyball like this.
Not in my outfit.
I got, I, this is my work.
I have to go.
Okay.
I'm going to go change.
I'm gonna go get ready for the beach!
I'm gonna go get ready for the beach.
Let's go get ready for the beach.
Ready for the beach.
Ready for the beach!
I'm changing right now.
I'm changing, changing.
Well, that could have been bad.
No,
I'm still changing.
What you saw was an illusion.
What you saw was an illusion, I think.
Probably.
What you saw was an illusion.
okay okay okay okay all right guys i think i've got my new
outfit on
oh no the world's rarest event ever happened it's the double
sun oh my gosh i can't believe it Oh no!
Wait, you're too blinded!
It's too bright!
You can't see!
Wait, hold on, I gotta- you gotta shadow too.
You gotta shadow too.
Hold on, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh!
Whoa!
I'm back.
I got swept away by those horrifying joggers on the beach.
Oh my gosh, we're okay, we're okay.
But I think we have to wait until the sun goes down for you
guys to see my name.
new outfit you can't even see it you're blinded you're blind
wait i'm gonna make you guys hold on actually i give up i'm
too lazy the evil joggers wait so you can't even see you
can't even see my my tippy toes or anything no but what if
you know actually i just realized i got carried away by
those joggers but what if what if they what if something
else happens that blocks the sun a little bit.
Oh!
Like that!
What even was that?
Whoa.
UFO don't go!
Did you guys see something?
Hold on.
The sun is going down a bit.
I'm sure.
Sure.
Let's see.
It is going down.
Look, as the sun goes down!
You can...
You are a little less blinded!
Wait, why is the first thing you see toes?
Ah!
Why is the first thing you see toes?
Well, I guess this is...
This answered my question, if you have socks or not.
I have no socks.
I have nothing.
I have nothing at all.
Oh, well.
Yeah.
Are you enjoying these?
Are you enjoying the dog?
The sun is getting lower.
Yes, yes.
Ever so slightly, ever so slightly.
I feel like I haven't I never do outfit reveals I don't know
how to do them you know I feel like I don't know how to do
them what is that what could that be what what could that be
no way was that was that metal gear right I mean the sun is
getting lower too I'll, you know...
Metal... Metal Gear Ray!
In the... Metal!
I cannot believe it!
In my own stream!
Honestly, this is just a lot of leg, isn't it?
It's just a lot of leg.
It's just a lot of leg going on here.
but you know we can keep going down a little bit more we go
down a little bit more leggy leggy leggy it's all legs it's
all legs but I feel a disturbance I think I think wait oh oh
they're back they're back
The joggers!
They're crazy!
They're just running up and down the beach!
They're running up and down the beach!
I guess I'll go down.
The sun is going down too, so...
War.
War is revealed.
Oh, what is that?
Maybe you saw a glimpse before.
Maybe you caught a little bit of a glimpse.
Yes.
Hmm.
More leggies.
but also a garter my mommy's favorite I mean mama loves to
put garter belts on everybody if you haven't noticed she's
always putting a garter belt on somebody wow that sun is
going down it's going down I also forgot to mention if short
hair as you can see my hair is quite short I got a little
bit of a haircut But also, long hair might be your fancy as
well.
Long hair as well, long hair as well.
The sun is going down, the sun is going down.
You can see, oh, cute!
Wait, do you see the bracelets?
So cute, so cute.
Oh.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
How embarrassing.
You guys, I'm starving.
I'm thinking of, I'm thinking, I want to get some, I want to
get some non-bread.
Oh, sorry.
Some non-curry.
I want to get some, I want to get some, I want to get some,
some, some bubble tea.
Wait, I missed the cue.
Wait, can you go back?
can we do that part again wait wait where was it wait I
missed it hold on hold on I want to get some food I want
some skitty wait wait hold on I have to restart it where am
I what's the script
I'm gonna zoom in some so you can't Oh, there it is!
There's my tommy!
I animated them too fast!
No, I mean, I mean, these are my thoughts in my brain.
Yes, yes, please.
Ooh!
Whoa!
As they...
Ooh!
Whoa, as they cover my thoughts of food, as they cover the
sun.
Whoa, little glimpses!
The sun is just about down, huh?
It is just about down, huh?
Maybe we can start going from here.
Some flowers!
Petals of white.
Yes.
So fancy.
So flowy.
Wait, wait, wait.
I didn't even show off so much.
So flowy.
Isn't it so nice?
Yeah.
Nice dress, perfect for the beats!
Yes, yes, yes.
Let's see what else.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Cute!
More... more frills?
Some...
Reborn?
Mm-hmm.
Some little armbands.
That kind of, that kind of remind me of like the bottom of
my dress.
Yeah, yeah.
The sun, oh, the sun is almost gone!
Once the sun is gone, I think you guys will be able to see
my face.
Oh my gosh, how mysterious.
How mysterious.
Look at that!
You can see my bathing suit!
I see just the tippy-tip-tip of the double sun.
It's just that bright that you're still blinded.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, cute, cute, cute two-piece bathing suit.
What a horrible night to have a curse.
It's not your fault.
in a million bajillion years double sun the curse it's not
your fault it happens every one in a billion bajillion
million years so you just got so unlucky you just got so
unlucky actually you know it is bright uh quite bright so
maybe something like this would be good to to to shield away
the light yeah And something else that I think you guys
can't see.
But for the reveal.
For the reveal.
I think it's a lot.
I think your vision.
It's adjusting.
Is it adjusting?
Is it?
Oh my gosh.
Oh
my gosh.
You guys can see me.
You guys can see me!
Hello!
What do we...
I can't...
I can't look at you guys.
I'm too embarrassed.
I can't look!
Actually, my eyes are still burning a little bit.
From...
From the sun!
Let's show the whole...
The whole...
Oh, I'll take off my sunglasses, but also...
I'm all ready for the beach!
I'm all ready to go out in summer.
I'm ready for a good time.
I'm ready for lots of sunny fun!
Yeah!
But there's one more big thing.
There's one more big thing that maybe you noticed in the...
silhouette thank you guys thank you you guys like it thank
you and that is you know unfortunately oh wait actually let
me show you the long hair first too
what do we think i like it quite a bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah But like I was saying,
unfortunately, it can't be summer all the time, you know?
Sadly.
Sadly, sadly, sadly.
It cannot be summer all the time.
So, I had a genius idea that I even though I want to feel
like summer, sometimes I can't wear stuff that's, you know,
my summer dress.
It might be too cold, so...
I have an extra special cardigan that I can wear for any
time when it's not summery and when I get a little bit...
little chili on those little chili nights look at this guy
look at him he's all shiny my little ghosty pin and I'll go
back to short hair with it what do you guys think actually I
sent one of my favorite cardigans to my mama and I said
Please!
I want this.
So do you guys...
Do you guys...
Do you guys like it?
Actually though, I kind of want to move areas.
Is it okay if we go somewhere else?
I want to go...
Let's hang out here at this nice and beautiful...
Seaside Extravagan Villa
What?
It feels really weird To finally show you guys Is it cute?
Is it cute?
Do you like it?
Please say yes.
I'm gonna take the cardigan off because I'm sweating so
much.
I'm so nervous.
I'm sweating so bad.
And my ectoplasm.
Ooh.
The cutest.
Yes, Mickey.
I have a proper hittai kakushi, my little ghost triangle
this time.
I got some cute little hair accessories.
And I got my bathing suit on, which do you guys want to see
the lower the the lower half of the bathing suit I will show
you for artists for
artists the
the reference sheet provided thank you very much Thank you
very much!
I
mean...
It's so cute!
I love... I love this outfit.
I'm so, so, so happy with it.
I think it's so stinking cute.
Yes, yes, yes.
Of course, I will post this later.
On... on... Twitter.
Uh...
And now, I have other things to talk about as well.
Other things, other things.
Um, maybe, uh, maybe you heard the BGM playing at the
beginning of the stream, which I will switch to now.
And if you so did enjoy it, maybe you noticed that there is
also a mysterious waiting room up on my on my channel at the
very very moment and I can say that it is
a new original song
new original song me new original song song premiering in
about with oh sorry 30 30 minutes i believe i got through
this a little faster than i expected to um new original song
in 30 minutes so i hope you guys will watch and listen and
listen and listen and listen lots and lots and lots it's by
a very beloved composer of mine uh kaseki saido san kaseki
saido san really thank you
Thank you so much.
Kaseki Sider.
You might not recognize the name, but he is the composer of
a song that I would sing very often in karaoke's and stuff.
And I also sang it in my 3D debut, Kuchitsuke Kibonu!
So, he...
He, um...
He wrote the lyrics for a really amazing song.
song and wrote this song as well so there will be english uh
uh lyrics uh in the closed caption so you can turn that on
and also you can read along in the description as well so
yes yes yes yes thank you thank you thank you yeah so um i'm
i'm i'm most honored ever to work with him um and then also
i have some other things maybe i will announce in a little
bit though because i but i wanted to announce the song so
after this the song or the stream will raid into the song
premiere and then after the song premiere it will raid into
my karaoke where we will well i will sing i will sing i will
sing i will sing i'm embarrassed to hide my face with my
glasses and my hat.
We'll sing too.
Yeah, pass the mic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it's a real buff.
It's a real buff.
I hope you guys will.
I wanted a really, I wanted a nice song that you could drive
to and just enjoy the summer with.
Incognito Minto.
They'll never know it's me.
I hope you guys like the outfit.
I guess I can do some toggly things too.
So, um, oh, one thing I wanted to show, which I thought was
kind of funny, was, um, I can actually, so, Sylia, Sylia
Papa, Rigby, so beautifully.
Thank you so much, Sylia.
You were amazing!
And one thing that Sylia always adds is being able to your
hair like your your bangs longer and i showed ayami mama
this and i was like it's it's too much like rem don't i look
so much like rem from zero
and actually it's so funny because i became a fan of ayami
mama through her I thought, wow, this is, I become Ayami
Rem.
It's like the biggest honor ever.
But Ayami Mama said I look a little yandere.
But I guess yandere would be a little more like, like smiley
crazy, huh?
Maybe.
But yeah, my bangs are a little bit longer.
They're kind of covering my eyes a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
And...
What else we got?
I don't know.
I could be Spaghetti.
I'll get the desk out of the way.
Smug.
Um...
So you guys really like it?
Do you actually really like it?
Do you actually really...
Do you actually like...
Like it?
I was so nervous.
I'm so nervous.
I'm still so nervous!
Ah!
Yeah.
I've had the idea for the...
uh...
for your summer dress for a while.
But I of course have to wait until summer!
I have to wait until summer!
So, hmm.
Now I'll go but you guys can see it all is glory
but also maybe i got a little maybe i wonder because doesn't
the fabric seem a little thin maybe it's not good quality of
a dress that i bought because what is this isn't the quality
the fabric a little thin it's a good thing i have my bathing
suit on underneath
It's perfect, I think so.
High quality, high quality, okay, if you say so, if you say
so.
See through like a ghost!
That's me, you can see my...
I've got my...
my triangle.
Yay, yay, I'm so happy!
I'm so happy!
Wow!
Let's see.
We have about 15 minutes before the premiere of my original
song.
So...
Let's, um...
Let me do a little bit more announcement.
Announcement.
So, maybe you're wondering...
Minto!
Your outfit is so cute!
Can we get green screens?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, give me a second.
We'll do it after.
Actually, no, we'll do it first, right?
We'll do it first.
But I cannot green screen.
I can only pink screen.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, I found.
There.
Okay, there.
Avert your eyes?
Whoa!
It's so bright!
We can do...
What should I do?
What should I...
What?
What do you want me to do?
My eyes!
Oh gosh, I'm so sorry, Vicky.
Wait, what time is it for you?
It's so early!
Swirly eye.
It's pink!
So you guys will like my outfit and...
And maybe some people will draw.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe.
Yes.
Wait, what if I'm, what if I'm crying?
Oh,
I have a long hair too.
Do you like the hair wiggles?
The... the loopies?
Look at them, look at them loop.
Isn't it kind of addicting?
It's kind of like hypnotic, I think.
Oh, the webulence.
Yeah.
Actually, my original song is about looping, too.
It's about like, never-ending looping or wanting a
never-ending looping summer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
the penalty when you look at my bathing suit okay
I have about 10 minutes so I have a couple things I would
like to share hopefully hopefully that sufficed hopefully
that was good for you guys first thing first thing first
thing first thing first thing you're like me though your
outfit is so cute do you have anything that I could possibly
purchase no but not yet there will be merch eventually here
I'm also gonna let's see I'm gonna put this in the corner
let's do this and then your wallet is safe today your wallet
is safe for a couple weeks actually I have a couple items
these are all mock-ups so they are subject to change but the
first thing is Your very own Minto hangar!
Your very own Minto hangar so you too can have Minto wearing
your...
If you say Minto, you're so cold in your dress, I need to
cover you up.
You can have Minto...
You can have Minto wearing...
Oh no, I'm not cold anymore.
So that's one thing.
That is probably my favorite thing actually.
Where do I put all these?
Oh gosh, I'm already running out of space.
The other things are a little more normal.
Next is a small Omamori with a very, very adorable art, the
key art for my outfit.
Minto protect you!
Omamori is like a little protection, little protection
amulet that you can carry around.
So, have me.
I'll scare away any other ghosts and evildoers.
Yeah, a charm, a charm, a charm.
Yes, yes, a talisman.
Talisman.
Yes, so, again, these were not on sale for a little bit of
time, but I'm just showing them off the off the mock-ups
today and
that the hot hot summer with of course with the with the art
yeah yeah yeah and so you two can fan yourself off I
actually collect it with you I so I specifically wanted this
one so very very summery summery items though they probably
will not arrive to you in the summer I'm so sorry but you
can also get all my money anytime of the year and you know
anytime so yeah the it's you are on my buddy and hangar
there is one more thing but where I'm waiting for for a for
there's some changes on it so I will once once the I will
announce once the merch page is up and all yes yes yes yes
yes for uses December 2027 the fan at least maybe you can
use the hanger anytime please hang up your clothes surely
not curse no no no no finally phantom so true so true so
true so true once once merch is up there will be a one month
buying period and one month buying period but it will be for
a couple weeks from now so I will announce that I just
reminded you to get your laundry out the dryer see and then
once you have your Minto hangar she'll she'll I don't know
haunt your closet or something put Minto in every part of
your home yes yes yes yes hold on I need a sippy
Yay!
You, you, you!
And I have two more things.
Two more things.
One thing is...
The EMP!
Coming to your area!
There will be a silent auction at Ofkai for a one-of-one.
Enormous minto plushie at Ofkai.
and it will be signed on the booty by me the EMP the
enormous minto plushie there will be a bidding sheet at the
Setsuna booth and if you want she is about three feet tall
so she's spread eagle you could have a spread eagle EMP in
your living room a true conversation piece to anyone Anyone
coming over, if you know how large the plushie that we just
put out is, here I'll show you this photo as well.
Hold on, wait, this is great.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You can see this is the original, this is the original
plushie.
She's giant!
Wait, yeah, there we go, okay.
And the original plushie is quite large.
I really hope though.
They give her underpants.
There's something.
My bathing suit is missing!
So yes, the one-of-one Minto EMP, enormous Minto plushie.
Thank you tofu sauce for creating it.
Spread eagle.
I was like, wow, the legs!
They were like, we made them a little big.
Maybe.
We have about five minutes Until The premiere And then into
karaoke How are we feeling, guys?
How... I know I keep saying I hope you like it, but I really
hope you like it I really hope you like it Almost time for
Ori-san Yeah, yeah, yeah It made my legs big so I could kick
it Booty So true Yeah.
You have it so cute!
Thank you!
Yes, yes, yes.
And you may...
You may...
hear the new song sung today if you so like it.
So definitely come to the karaoke.
And I know I announced...
I did announce the song.
I announced the merch eventually.
I announced the EMP.
I have one last announcement.
This is...
This is for everybody.
If you so wish.
Aww.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Free wallpaper!
If you so like one.
Free wallpaper.
drawn by the beautiful marina for your super summary of
wallpaper needs yes yes so this will be up for free for
everybody anybody can download it I'll put it up probably
after the karaoke stream so just be a little patient but
there's also a Sun hat version and if you say oh Minto your
short hair is so cute but I'm actually a long hair enjoyer.
Long hair version!
And if you say, Minto, your long hair is so beautiful, but
I'm also a sun hat enjoyer.
All four variations will be up for you guys.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
So long hair version.
Short hair version.
Sun hat version.
No sun hat version.
All for you.
to enjoy yeah so like i said i'll put those up i'll put
those up uh probably have to karaoke stream
i guess it's almost time just a few minutes to go to the
premiere i hope you guys will watch it i hope you guys will
listen lots and stream it and um it will be on streaming
platforms um which is kind of crazy my first I have two
other original songs but neither are on YouTube yet
officially and but this one will be up and also be on
streaming platforms so yes yes the others will will
eventually as well but I just have to get around to doing it
yeah yeah yeah I hope you guys like it I hope you guys like
it I'm so happy I'm so happy I'm so happy I feel so summery
and so cute and maybe eventually be on the lookout in the
opening animation for the new outfit perhaps.
Maybe?
I say that.
I say maybe.
I don't know.
Why am I saying maybe?
Maybe.
Yay!
Alright, well I'm gonna go send you guys over to the...
um uh oh i guess i should say the name of the song the song
name is ura meshi summer or if that's a little hard to say
you can call it also lingering summer so that um is the name
of the song i'm gonna go change all of the stuff for it and
add all the description and everything and everything so
yeah thank you everybody thank you for the day for you you
guys like it thank you so much and i will see you hopefully
in 15 minutes for um for karaoke bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye